[Musique]
certaines personnes disent que c'est à
cause d'un virus
c'est vrai que ça semble plus logique
qu'un événement apocalyptique
d'envergure biblique un virus paraît
plus probable une chose minuscule
invisible comportant nous un groupe de
molécules un ensemble de commandes des
fragments de code microscopiques qui
circule partout où il y a d'la vie et
qui cherche à se fixer sur toute
créature vivante pour y répandre un
programme maléfique
oui en effet un virus me paraît bien
plus probable
[Musique]
ah merde haha tu pourrais m'aider au
lieu de rester là me regarder
[Musique]
y'en a encore
on n'a que quelques secondes cours
à déclencher les explosifs
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que tu attends les
marcels caisse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu es vraiment sûr qu'on devrait pas
chercher un médecin
les gens qui sont gravement blessés
crève les gens qui ont une maladie qui
nécessite des soins médicaux crève
on n'a pas besoin d'un médecin
[Musique]
on n'a pas besoin d'un médecin mais ça
va arriver
alors pourquoi prendre le risque ça
c'est ce que tu crois tu crois qu'un
médecin va t'aider à comprendre c'est
n'importe quoi
une perte de temps ce qu'il faut faire
c'est qu'on se déplace et qu'on attaque
aussi vite et fort que possible jusqu'à
ce qu'ils crèvent tous de faim ou de
soif et qu'ils disparaissent les
l'information c'est le pouvoir et on a
besoin d'information si on veut garder
l'initiative pas ce genre d'information
et si on était obligé de se cacher dans
un désert en attendant que tout est fini
de pt dans le désert on aura clairement
besoin d'un médecin j'ai planifié tout
ça et tout ce qu'il nous faut c'est deux
camions chargés avec c'est trop
dangereux
ils vont attaquer quand on s'y attendra
le mois et à ce moment là on pourra rien
faire tu sais que c'est faux la première
fois qu'on s'est rencontrés toi et moi
là c'était dangereux
et toi t'as fait quoi contre ça
t'attendais juste un grand boum
et tu crois toujours qu'il vont nettoyer
ça avec des bombes atomiques seulement
avec les bombardiers je te le dis avec
les missiles tactiques ou les missiles
de croisière on n'entendra rien avant
l'explosion mais on change de sujet là
écoute à un moment ou à un autre il
faudra bien qu'on s'arrête quelque part
et à ce moment là on aura besoin d'un
médecin écoute quand on pourra envisager
de s'arrêter quelque part pourquoi pas
ouais mais en attendant on fait comme
j'ai dit et pas autrement
on se déplace et en attaque et c'est
nous qui choisissons où et quand frappe
mais je crois pas que ce soit ça le
problème
tu es trop curieux c'est tout et la
curiosité va te tuer nos cachets trop
curieux et alors quoi je te suis pas là
toi tu les pas même un peu curieux tu te
réveilles un jour et tu découvres que
les gens se sont transformées en une
espèce de saloperies de zombies
assoiffés de sang et tu veux pas savoir
ce qui s'est passé ça t'intéresse même
pas non pas du tout
bon je vais avoir besoin de réchauffer
des produits chimiques
j'espère que tu te rappelles que c'est
mon tour de choisir la prochaine
destination faut trouver un endroit
assez grand histoire de pas tomber dans
une embuscade d'accord un hôpital à toi
de choisir lequel
ban
paul est positif
[Musique]
abracadabra que la lumière soit
annoncée
vous le connaissez bien cet hôpital
ouais chambre 318 bâtiment c on se
retrouve là bas enfermez vous et
attendez nou camp
ça va aller
louis borie
on n'a vraiment pas de chance recherchez
un médecin et on tombe sur une
infirmière avec une km je vous signale
que ma soeur et médecin chef pas
infirmière et je suis pas une gamine moi
j'ai dit ce que devrait pas nous donner
trop de détails on se connaît à peine et
en plus on t'as même pas posé de
question on n'a pas le temps pour ça il
faut qu'on sorte d'ici ça va pas
paniquer c'est une de nos bonbons la
piège et tout le bâtiment
ça c'est pas normal
si vous êtes derrière cette porte vous
conseille de vous d'éloigner la paix
qu'est ce qu'on fait en bouche on n'a
pas le temps aide-moi avec le lit
entre et il se comprend mieux maintenant
alors c'était vous qui avait posé des
bombes un peu partout dans l'hôpital
vraiment classe maintenant il vous reste
plus qu'à les déclenche c'est bien aux
chocs c'est ça qu'est ce que tu veux toi
tu veux savoir ce que je sais que ça
lorsque je regarde ça regarde ça c'est
bon oui je suis entêté tu comprends ça
je suis carrément avec des [ __ ] alors
ce que je sais que vous sortiez ce truc
de moi je veux guerre je veux guérir
d'accord c'est vous qui allez vous
occuper de ça vous et personne d'autre
je savais bien que vous finiriez par
venir et c'est vous et votre armée alors
tout ce que je veux c'est que vous
sortiez ce truc de moi tu connais ce cas
on peut dire qu'on se connaît toute ma
vie j'ai dû me cacher à cause de mecs
comme les thés quoi toi un général n'ont
tenté un peu trop jeune pour ça tu dois
sûrement être capitaine ou commandant du
colonel suphin je parie que tu es un
[ __ ] de colonel il a raison sur un
point ouais mon boulot c'était aussi de
traquer les 5es de son espèce
alors ouais on peut dire qu'on se
connaît on ne prend pas de haut comme ça
avec des propositions pour me parler
comme ça mon pote c'est moi qui ai l
avantage sur toi ils peuvent pas me voir
je suis affecté
ça veut dire que je suis invisible
complètement invisible alors vous allez
m'aider je vous conseille de me trouver
un antidote
allez on bouge allez venez go
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu le connaissais même pas pas
personnellement
on aurait dû le tuer contre 9 l occasion
tu l'as laissé s'enfuir
tu as eu pitié de lui
c'est bien la première fois que je te
vois te laisser emporter par l'émotion
il est déjà mort ok et toi tu as ton
médecin chez avec tt militaire un
officier je l'avait deviné
ça doit pas être facile de tuer des gens
normaux des gens pas infecté quoi c'est
vrai que lui il a dit qu'il était
infecté
tu as compris ce qu'il voulait dire par
là lui mort ou plus ça vous devriez
arrêter de vous poser trop de questions
peut-être qu'il serait temps de nous
expliquer la situation vous croyez pas
alors vous êtes médecin je suis sûr vous
comprenez mieux ce qui se passe que nous
qu'est-ce qu'il avait lui il n'avait pas
l'air infectés en fait il avait presque
l'air dans son état normal non vous
voyez ce que je veux dire il lui dit
qu'il s'est fait mordre et pourtant il
reste lui-même il ya une période
d'incubation ok mais comment il a été
infectée à la base il s'est forcément
fait mordre par l'un d'entre eux ces
blessures c'était c'était pas des traces
de morsures d'animal vous croyez que
laisse tomber on aura le temps de parler
de ça plus tard il doit être quasiment 9
heures on pourrait allumer la radio
histoire et c'est vrai on a failli
oublier que c'était bientôt l'heure vous
l'écoutez aussi way tous les jours tu
crois que c'est vraiment lui qui parle
ou qui est enregistré chez pas mais il
faut bien quelqu'un pour diffuser ça ça
doit être c'est soit une émission de
radio diffusée en direct soit un
programme enregistré diffusé tous les
jours à 9 heures à temps
qu'est ce qui t'arrive à toi normalement
c'est mon rôle à moi d'être cynique
celui qui a des émotions
toi tu joue un rôle de la foire et tu te
souviens le mec déterminer le mec dénuée
d'émotion toujours prêt à passer à
l'acte pour écouter cette émission ça a
déjà dû commencer
[Musique]
peut-être que c'est à cause des rongeurs
petit insaisissable sans pitié ils
répandent la maladie et la mort car il
mange les restes des plus forts et
s'attaque aux plus faibles en ce temps
là ils sortaient de leurs repères la
nuit pour piller les nids des dinosaures
et à force de dévorer leurs oeufs
ils ont mis fin à l' espèce entière
c'est peut-être cela la nature du
progrès le nouveau dévore l'ancien il le
déchiquette jusqu'à ce qu'il n'en reste
plus rien le progrès est peut-être par
essence un genre d'extinction inévitable
comme le temps et la mort
bienvenue dans mon laboratoire
[Musique]
tu peux me rappeler ce qu'on est censé
faire exactement on doit fabriquer des
pièges pour une attaque
le but c'est d'attirer les infectés
ayant les massacres je sais ça a l'air
un peu bizarre comme ça notre premier
réflexe elle devrait plutôt être de se
retrancher quelque part ou alors de
s'enfuir pour passeur prendre au piège
et d'éviter les problèmes mais non mais
attends et ça j'avais compris on doit
prendre l'initiative on les travaille
qu'on les chasse et pas l'inversé
ce que je te demande c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on est censé faire avec de l'eau et
et tous électret l'électrode ouais bien
en fait on sait par les atomes présents
dans l'eau et ont créé un firmament
qu'on appellera le ciel c'est une
électrolyse
ça c'est par l'eau en atomes d'hydrogène
et d'oxygène
le but du jeu c'est de créer une grande
quantité d'hydrogène dans un espace
réduit comme ça au moment opportun
il suffira d'une étincelle et paume tout
va exploser d'un coup a en théorie bien
sûr en réalité j'ai essayé plusieurs
fois et ça un peu foiré je crois que la
quantité d'hydrogène que j'ai créé
n'était pas suffisante par rapport à mon
espace réduit
je sais pas peut-être que c'est un
problème d'étanchéité au peut-être qu'il
aurait fallu plus de récipients bref
quoiqu'il en soit me voilà ce qu'on fait
ici
impressionnant merci
je suis content que quelqu'un apprécié
mon originalité c'est pas comme lui tnt
poudre à canon
c'est tout ce qui m'intéresse mais je
parlais de la métaphore c'est comme dire
qui transforme l'eau ainsi ça c'est pas
moi qui trouvais ça ça vient d'un
fanatique religieux qui traînait sur un
forum que je gérais un genre de pseudo
scientifique ou un truc comme ça le
genre de mec qui cherche à expliquer la
bible scientifiquement tu vois alors en
fait il avait une théorie qui dit que
dieu recréer le ciel comme ça en
transmettant un courant électrique dans
les eaux préhistorique c'est une bonne
théorie
moi je trouvais ça un peu trop facile je
lui ai dit et comment tu expliques la
présence d'ozone dans l'air et j'attends
toujours sa réponse pour la présence d
azote dans l'air ou pour la création du
ciel ouais
ça plaît ça sert à quoi
j'ai l'impression d'entendre mon père
pourquoi il faudrait trouver une utilité
à tous pourquoi on pourrait pas juste
faire les choses naturellement je trouve
ça joli ou pas esthétiquement ouais mais
ça sert à rien c'est ça et tu crois pas
que la beauté est une fin en soi qu'elle
pourrait exister seulement pour être ce
que l' on ne fait jamais rien sans qu'il
y ait une vraie raison
tu crois pas genre manger quelque chose
parce que c'est bon oh écoutez de la
musique vous faire un dessin juste pour
s'amuser
ok si tu as fini tu vas apprendre à se
servir d'un fusil
c'est pas croyable tepa éculés tu perds
jamais de vue l'objectif
le fait d'avoir un objectif on peut
aussi voir quelque chose de beau je te
montre pas juste un bordel ils ont
réussi à rentrer rien
go go go
bien qu'une entrée et surveillaient la
bien pour construire d'ici négatif à
l'extérieur ils peuvent arriver de
n'importe quelle direction
ici il ya deux issues brute en plus tu
m'as dit que le docteur arrivait dès
qu'elle sera revenu on pourra se marient
d'ici tous les quatre
grenade
[Musique]
c'est bon elle est là en rouge
comptez
allez démarre
[Musique]
c'est la deuxième fois qu'ils nous
attaquent sans qu'on s'y attende il ya
un truc qui va pas c'est pas grave
qu'ils attaquent sans qu'on s'y attende
ce qui est grave c'est que c'est pas la
première fois qu'on se fait attaquer par
le côté que tu devais surveiller et au
lieu de lui apprendre à tirer comme on
l'avait prévu
toi tu joues à l'alchimiste
j'ai toujours pas eu de réponse
je te le dis moi tout ce que j'ai vu de
mes propres yeux c'est que le temps
entre l'infection et le déclenchement de
cette mère peut varier de quelques
secondes à plusieurs minutes mais j'ai
pas vu ça sur beaucoup de personnes
alors ça vaut ce que ça vaut
c'est aussi ce que je pensais jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et c'est ce que disaient les
rapports officiels quand il y avait
encore des rapports les sega à l'hôpital
rien qui prouve qu'il était vraiment
affecté je sais pas je sais pas comment
l'expliquer mais je crois qu'il disait
la vérité
on sait pas ce que c'est que ce truc et
on sait pas non plus comment ça se
transmet alors laisse tomber tu veux on
ne sait pas qui il est ni où il est de
toute façon c'est pas avec moi qu'il
faut parler de ça
en ce qui me concerne c'est terminé mais
si tu insistes va le voir lui
maintenant si tu veux bien j'ai des
affaires plus importantes à régler pour
le moment
prenez une pause
buvez un peu d'eau
jamais perdre de vue l'objectif il est
comme papa ces derniers on dirait mais
en fait non je tomberai pas dans son
piège
[Musique]
vous êtes sûr que c'est pas un peu tôt
tu es mieux entraînés que la plupart des
recrues que j'ai vu partir sur le
terrain tu en fais pas plus vite tu
seras habitué à tuer plus vite on pourra
passer à autre chose
combien de temps ça va encore durer
combien de temps on va devoir faire des
pièges se balader avec des fusils et tu
es encore quelques mois et ce sera fini
je te promets que ce que je marque sera
bientôt terminé tu verras on se trouvera
un endroit sympa où habitait et on
oubliera tout cette histoire
ok il faudra toujours quand on reste sur
nos gardes se tenir prêts avec des armes
et à d'ordre s'est jamais vraiment
terminé
on a quelques pauses de temps en temps
c'est tout tu peux pas croire un truc
pareil dont le deux façons de voir les
choses par la lunette d'un fusil tu
espères pas quelque chose de mieux
quelque chose d'autre bravo alors
fonctionner au vous auriez dû voir ça
quand ça a pété ils ont pris un gros
nuage de vapeur en pleine gueule
bref allez voir ça ça a marché toute
l'eau s'est transformée en vapeur voilà
alors que des explosifs ça aurait suffi
ça aurait même été mieux c'est peut-être
comme ça que les ciels a été créé une
grosse source de chaleur de l'eau en
ébullition c'est que de la vapeur non
attends attends si si la température est
assez haute
mais vraiment très haute les molécules
d'eau vont se désintégrer mais
maintenant le cours de chimie est
terminée on a du travail qui nous attend
il en reste encore
il est possible qu'il se soit entretuer
les dinosaures prédateurs ont simplement
désobéi aux lois de l'équilibré tout
comme les êtres humains peut-être qu'un
ou plusieurs dinosaures sont devenus
aussi bien programmé pour tuer qui l'on
taira dickey des espèces et entière ça
ne semble pas probable car l'écosystème
est censée intervenir plus la population
des proies diminue et plus la population
des prédateurs diminue permettant ainsi
à la population des proies d'augmenter
et ainsi de suite
la seule exception que nous connaissons
c'est l'homme mais qui nous dit que
l'homme et le sol
[Musique]
avant que ça commence je regardais ces
trucs là pendant des heures pour voir la
force primitive la création de matière
et ex nihilo
il n'y a pas plus grande vérité que ça
faut qu'on y aille
[Applaudissements]
pas capté quelque chose depuis le début
du black up non par le gars qui parle
des dinosaures et du toi tu crois qu'il
ya toujours un gouvernement en place
mais est toujours quelque chose
c'est le principe même de notre
civilisation et en a un qui donne des
ordres aux autres qui leur dit quoi
faire et en échange il peut les
exploiter
c'est bien rodé alors selon la
définition ci a pas de gouvernement il
n'y a pas de civilisation
je sais pas s'il y avait vraiment un
gouvernement
à mon avis nettoierait la zone avec des
bombes nucléaires
et puis nous avec ça finira peut-être
par arriver qui sait
ouais si c'est comme ça on saura rien
avant que tout soit fini ça ça dépend
s'ils utilisent des missiles tactiques
là on les entendra pas venir mais si
c'est des avions est là il ya deux
options s'il envoie un bombardier comme
le b 52
on aura peut-être une chance de de
l'entendre arriver avant que la bombe
nous pète à la gueule sinon il pourrait
aussi envoyé des avions supersoniques
là on n'entendra rien parce que ils sont
super sonic mais tu vas peut-être
entendre un grand boum avant même que la
bombe ne touche le sol
après il y aura un grand flash de
lumière comment la chaleur est ensuite
ce sera la fin tu souris
c'est la première fois que je te vois
sourire fire finalement tu as réussi à
trouver quelqu'un pour écouter tes
théories à la con tu lui a raconté ce
que tu faisais avant que ça commence
non il tenait un site web qui tentait de
réfuter la plupart des théories du
complot
maintenant monsieur y croit dur comme
fer le rasoir d'occam c'est
l'explication la plus simple et la plus
logique qui est souvent la meilleure
à votre avis où est-ce qu'ils sont
passés nos gouvernements tout d'un coup
un pourquoi il ya toujours d'électricité
et d'eau courante
tu en penses quoi toi et ils s'en
servent d'armes biologiques c'est tout
j'en suis persuadé c'est l'explication
la plus simple et la plus logique c'est
comme ça c'est à ton tour de monter la
garde
qui t'as perdu dix mois beaucoup de gens
toi toujours sur la défensive
tu te reposes jamais en fait jamais
c'est pas grave je comprendrais si tu
veux pas en parler ça va j'ai tout perdu
tout le monde ça peut pas être pire
parents enfants marie cousins oncles
je t'ai dis ça peut pas être pire
ça peut toujours être pire je vois la
situation a l'air désespéré je comprends
ton point de vue mais tu sais les choses
changent pas pour moi moi j'ai passé
toute ma vie à tuer et à ordonner de
tuer je suis responsable de la création
et du développement de nouvelles
méthodes de destruction qui serait
incompréhensible pour des gens comme toi
alors si tu veux tout savoir pour moi
rien n'a changé c'est pas du tout la
même chose
c'était pas des femmes et des enfants ou
ta propre famille écoute j'ai passé ma
vie entière à voir des gens mourir pour
toutes sortes de raisons en même temps
j'en ai vu d'autres qui guérissait et
que cette souffrance avait fait mûrir
malgré tout à l'heure tu as raison
rien n'a changé c'est ça que je veux
dire
je sais que même maintenant il ya de
l'espoir
on a eu quelques heures mais il y en a
d'autres qui arrivent
c'est la troisième fois c'est pas un
accident il ya quelqu'un qui les attire
vers nous on verra ça plus tard en
bouche
[Musique]
je
il vient
[Musique]
je commence à penser que c'est peut-être
le gall l'hôpital
après tout il a réussi à esquiver tout
le piège
et en plus il nous a dit clairement que
les autres ne le voyais pas si les
infectés ne s'attaque pas à lui doit
forcément y avoir une raison tandis
qu'au delà peut-être qu'ils les attire
vers nous et qu'ils se plantent juste
après c'est possible way trouve nous un
plan si c'est vraiment lui qui les
attire vers nous il va falloir le
neutraliser
il est 11 heures on a raté l'émission
c'est la première fois que je rappelais
mission alors tu crois qu'ils se
connaissent ou pas je sais pas c'est pas
très clair tu l'as dis toi même ils
auraient dû le tuer quand on était à
l'hôpital mais il n'a pas fait ça lui
ressemble pas je sais que je ne connais
pas bien mais je pense que c'est
vraiment pas son jour tu as raison
j'avais jamais vu hésiter à tirer mais
pour tout dire je l'avais jamais vu avec
quelqu'un de vivant enfin quelqu'un de
normal de pain affecté quoi ce qui est
sûr c'est que c'est un vrai militaire
peut-être que tuer des civils en leur
tirant dans le dos ça va contre sa
nature
tu vois ce que je veux dire la morale du
guerrier et tout ça je pense que ça ça
lui correspond bien tu sais je me suis
dit exactement la même chose quand j'ai
rencontré beaucoup trop jeune pour être
général trop confiants et expérimentés
pour être un simple commandant je sais
pas tout ce que je sais c'est qu'on
devrait les rejoindre
ils sont sûrement déjà en train de
sécuriser les lieux s'il ya vraiment
quelqu'un qui cherche à les attirer vers
nos faut qu'on installe des explosifs
tout autour de nous ça sert à rien de se
cacher si c'est vrai
[Musique]
merci
c'est quoi ça c'est encore une de mes
nouvelles expériences
je crée de la terre avec de l'eau tu
vois la cage elle est plongée dans l'eau
et je fais passer un courant faible à
travers grâce à ça les particules qui
lie à dans l'eau vont venir se coller
tout autour de la cage du coup en
théorie avec le temps va y avoir à cette
particule pour créer un genre de petite
île qui va remplacer la cage
[Musique]
je crois qu'on ferait mieux de rentrer
ouais
ouais aller non mais c'est sympa ouais
c'est ça
s'il est vraiment à nos trousses il doit
connaître cet endroit ça veut dire qu'il
va ramener les infectés ce soir ou
demain tu as un plan j'ai toujours un
plan sous la main c'est pour ça que tu
me supportent s'appelait que je te
rendent dingue avec mes théories en fait
[Musique]
oh
j'aurais dû m'en douter vous traquez
c'est ça vous n'avez rien d'autre à
faire ça vous éclater de me traquer
comme un chien bouge pas ne bouge pas je
comprends mieux maintenant
il vous a dit que vous deviez vous
monsieur moi c'est ça que c'était
dangereux
moi c'est de lui dont vous devriez vous
méfier
c'est lui qui a massacré toute sa
famille pas moi dealer colonna dealer un
peu qu'ils tuaient bouge pas stop ne
bouge pas aimé tes mains sur la tête ils
étaient tous tués avec son propre
flingue à bout portant sa mère ses
enfants sa nièce qui n'était encore
qu'un bébé c'est la vérité c'est la
stricte vérité
quand c'est un civil qui tue quelqu'un
ça dit un criminel un meurtrier
mais par contre toi quand tu quelqu'un
avec ton uniforme
le hic vient héros quand un civil tué 20
personnes
c'est un psychopathe un tueur en série
par contre un soldat un soldat alors à
sa médaille
arrête ça le jour où un militaire
réussie par hasard à faire des centaines
de morts des milliers de morts il
devient un héros national s'est vendu
des millions vers dieu on écrit
carrément des poèmes pour lui il devient
une vraie figure de légende
arrête ça suffit ils ont tous peur de
moi il me méprise tous quand ça a
commencé
il avait encore des soldats avec lui il
aurait pu sauver sa famille en les
isolant
il aurait pu sauver leur vie s'occuper
d'eux il aurait suffi d'un seul de ces
hommes pour aller tous les sauver mais
non non pas lui il a préféré partir lui
même pour leur mettre une balle
sans aucune exception en plein dans la
tête il les a tous exécutés et le voilà
le héros de la nation le noble guerrier
des temps modernes
t'es juste un [ __ ] de psychopathe au
service de la loi
rien de plus sa mère ses enfants et à
bout portant
dealer colonel qu'est ce que ça t'a fait
d'assassiner ta propre famille non
pourquoi taper sa [ __ ] de merde aurait
pu attendre un peu il savait des trucs
tu aurais pu attendre
j'ai déjà vu ça avant il était sur le
point de mourir
et toi alors tu le connaissais ou pas
pourquoi pas hésité au lieu de le tuer
tout simplement pourquoi t'as hésité
cette fois qu'est ce que ça change
il est mort encore une attaque tous en
position
[Musique]
une météorite
pourquoi pas après tout qu'est ce qui
pourrait causer une extinction aussi
soudaine à par un élément extérieur
sorti de nulle part pour tout anéantir
comme dans un film catastrophe de rely
good ou dans un mythe apocalyptique mais
peut-être que ce n'est là que le reflet
d'une de nos plus grandes peurs notre
incapacité à contrôler notre destin
la certitude que quoi que nous fassions
la mort nous guette en permanence
absolue définitive comme un incendie
impossible à arrêter
évidemment il est possible qu'il l'ait
vu mais qu'il n'ai jamais compris ce que
c'était peut-être qu'en ce moment même
cette menace est devant nos yeux mais
que comme les dinosaures
nous ne pouvons ni le voir ni l'entendre
comme lorsque notre cerveau décide de ne
plus entendre un son qui le dérange
[Musique]
alors tu le connaissais ou pas quand je
t'ai demandé de préparer cet endroit je
t'ai dit qu'il fallait tuer les poissons
de cet aquarium
ça va attirer les chats et ça finira par
attirer pire que ça t'es pas répondu à
ma question tout le temps et l'énergie
que tu passes sur 7
cette machine à alimenter des poissons
on n'a pas assez de temps pour ça est-ce
que tu le connaissais ou pas je te le
dis je le connaissais pas
personnellement
et ça change rien parce qu'il est mort
donc on s'en fout de la vérité il ya un
truc que tu veux pas nous dire tu sais
ce qui s'est passé et comment ça a
commencé
tu le sais tu le sais et tu veux pas
nous gagnions ference a fait que je t'en
parle ou pas ça change rien de toute
façon tu as deviné tout seul ce qui
s'était passé
oui ça a été provoquée par des essais
d'armes biologiques
oui ça a mal tourné oui alors tu le
savais depuis tout ce temps tu le savais
et tu nous l'a pas dit tu connais c'est
la raison de ce foutoir et coquet mais
toi aussi tu le savais je comprends pas
pourquoi tu fait l'innocent tout est pas
encore demandé pourquoi les infectés se
bouffent entre eux peut-être pourquoi
ils attaquent les gens sains toi avec
toutes les théories de complot tu avais
compris dès que ça a commencé c'était la
seule explication logique tu savais que
tout ça avait été provoqué par un essai
d'un biologique
alors qu'est ce que ça change que je te
le dise puisque tu savais déjà tous tes
un scientifique
c'est à cause de votre soif de
connaissances maladive qu'on en est là
sans toi et tes intello de potes qui
veulent toujours tout savoir tout
comprendre
on n'en serait pas là aujourd'hui écoute
se comprendre qu'il soit encore 90 lui
il était assis derrière son écran à
créer des virus informatiques
ses amis et collègues eux ils étaient en
train de créer un truc dangereux
vraiment dangereux et il aurait très
bien pu faire partie de ces gars là si
tu tiens tant à connaître la vérité ne
te ment pas à toi même
on est tous plus ou moins des [ __ ]
c'est ça la vérité tu es au courant de
ce qui se passe alors arrête de jouer
d'innocents et arrête de te lamenter
passe
je t'ai pas dit ce que je savais j'ai
pas de temps à perdre avec ces
discussions ridicule on a jusqu'à midi
pour poser des explosifs un peu partout
ces derniers jours on a fait sauter nos
pièges beaucoup trop rapidement on a du
retard à rattraper
alors arrêtez de vous leurrer ça
s'arrangera pas comme ça les infectés
vont être de plus en plus violent et
agressif et si on doit se retrouver au
mauvais endroit et au mauvais moment on
va se faire tuer alors reposez-vous je
vais voir si la voix est libre pendant
ce temps là ne jugez pas trop vite
vous avez entendu ce qui s'est passé il
a été obligé de tuer sa famille de ses
propres mains en plus d'avoir tout perdu
je me suis très souvent disputés avec
papa à propos de l'euthanasie est ce que
j'aurai le courage de le faire s'il le
fallait je tombe pas dans son piège
le confond pas avec tapas
on y va
dt tas c'est dingue de se dire qu'il ya
des grenouilles qui baisent label elles
se reproduisent
ok alors à ton avis imagine qu'on prenne
un poisson au hasard et qu'on le mette
l'attend est ce que tu crois qu'au bout
d'un moment il va se reproduire
absolument mais voudrait mieux pas faire
ça parce qu'ils finiraient électrocuté à
coup sûr ouais mais au moins il aura eu
la chance de faire l'amour avant que ça
s'arrête
maintenant je comprends pourquoi tu veux
pas en parler
je suis désolé ta femme tes enfants
parents frères et soeurs nièces
j'ai tout perdu sans exception avec mon
arme de service à bout portant
ça s'est passé comme il a dit ça peut
pas être pire je suis désolé ça peut
toujours être pire je me souviens d'une
patiente qui était en phase terminale
on a fait une demande au tribunal pour
avoir le droit de l'euthanasie pour
qu'elle ait une chance de mourir
dignement
quand on a eu l'autorisation elle a
insisté pour que ce soit la plus jeune
de ses filles qui s'en occupe que ce
soit elle qui qu'il a des branches et
cette fille elle habitait à l'autre bout
du monde
il a fallu une semaine pour la contacter
et une autre semaine pour qu'elle aille
et pendant tout ce temps sa mère vivait
un véritable enfer on l'a suppliée de
laisser tomber mais elle voulait
l'attendre à tout prix
alors quand sa fille est arrivée qu'elle
a mis fin à tout ça j'ai parlé un peu
avec elle quand elle parlait de sa mère
elle parlait d'une femme très dur et
très sévère qu'il avait passé toute sa
vie à critiquer à commander jamais
gentilleau compréhensive réconfortante
et elle soutenait qu'elle lui aurait
tout pardonner si sa mère lui avait dit
juste une fois qu'elle l'aimait
quand j'ai entendu ça je lui ai dit
votre mère ne vous a pas dit qu'elle
vous aimait elle l'a eue relais pour que
vous l'entendiez à l'autre bout du monde
[Musique]
ah ouais
dix minutes de pause et on prépare les
explosifs
on n'est pas assez agressif ça peut pas
durer comme ça on doit vraiment rien
lâcher
j'irais bien à la plage moi c'est pas
trop mon genre d'aller à la plage
j'aurais aimé présenter mon père une
semaine avec lui et il serait devenu
accro à l'océan c'était un vrai pirate
il fallait le voir en tout cas c'était
un pro pour la pêche il disait qu'il
voulait dessiner rails en mer comme les
vikings des funérailles de viking
c'est quoi
couché sur un bateau et dérivant vers le
grand large avec ses armes et ses objets
fétiches un truc comme ça pendant que
les flammes consume lentement son bateau
c'est bon ça je sais pas trop je
préférerais mourir en faisant l'amour
c'est la première fois que tu te fait
griffer ou mordre par l'un d'entre eux
de quoi tu parles tu le sais très bien
je te parle des griffures qui t'ont fait
dans le couloir on ne la fait pas à toi
surtout quand il s'agit de la santé
c'est mon métier tu te souviens
mais n'a pas répondu à ma question ça
m'était déjà arrivé à moi aussi
dès que ça a commencé ça voudrait dire
alors que c'est pas contagieux
peut-être que le virus ne se transmet
pas par des morsures ou alors ça
pourrait être le temps d'incubation qui
est très long quoi qu'il en soit il
faudrait qu'on sache si ça se trouve on
est infecté il faudrait qu'on s'éloigne
d'eux pour leur sécurité
imagine qu'on soit ensemble quand ça va
se déclencher
qu'est ce que j'en sais moi c'est bon ça
sert à rien de jouer la comédie plus
longtemps
crois moi je leur dirai rien de quoi tu
parles tu sais très bien de quoi je
parle c'est pas une coïncidence
t'en fais pas je sais très bien ce que
tu ressens pour moi aussi le monde
s'écroule sauf que pour moi c'est
nouveau j'ai jamais vu un truc pareil
c'est peut-être que tu as besoin de te
calmer un peu comme je l ai déjà dit en
ce qui me concerne
rien n'a changé tu vas pas encore faire
ça tu attaques pour contourner le sujet
je refuse de jouer à ce jeu là mais il
ya des choses qui n'ont pas changé c'est
vrai mais il ya des blessures il ya des
blessures que nul ne peut guérir
aucun docteur aucun humain le temps non
plus personne
on sait assez reposé on y va
promet le mois
prends mais moi que quand tout ça sera
terminé on va on va élever des poissons
sans être obligé les électrocuter et
même des poissons rouges et des
salamandres et des départs tuteur de ce
que tu voudras allez faut préparer les
explosifs
essayez vous savez déjà vous servir
d'armes légères il est temps pour vous
de vous familiariser avec le maniement
des explosifs
[Musique]
une autre théorie évoque une éruption
volcanique
pas une seule éruptions volcaniques mais
des milliers la pression s'est accumulée
pendant des millions d'années
et un beau jour elle s'est libérée une
force inouïe a surgi des entrailles de
la terre et l'atmosphère s'est chargé de
poussières et de gaz mortel qui cachait
le soleil empoisonnait le sol l'air
l'eau
quoi de plus effrayant que l'idée que
sous nos pieds la mort nous guette
qu'elle vient de ceux là mêmes qui nous
permet de vivre de ceux là même où nous
trouvons refuge dans la vie comme dans
la mort
[Musique]
j'ai réussi ça marche ça fait des mois
je suis dessus c'est parfait cette fois
il pourra pas dire que c'est une
efficace rien ces trucs très discret il
ya via une télécommande une caméra c'est
génial on pouvait pas rêver mieux c'est
parfait un robot télécommandé équipé
d'une caméra miniature c'est sûr qu'avec
ça on isolé je t'avais que tu dirais ça
mais ce robot peut monter et descendre
les escaliers regarde rien après je
comprends pas ça marchait tout à la
tolkien palace pas la faire
tu sais quoi à la fac un de mes profs de
médecine disait tout le temps en
rigolant qu dans la genèse il y avait
deux versions de la création de l'homme
il disait que la première marche est pas
très bien alors dieu aurait essayé
ouais enfin faut dire que le deuxième
essai n'était pas très concluant non
plus il a dû sortir la version bêta un
peu trop vite avant de corriger tous les
bugs
la version bêta ouais la version bêta tu
sais comme pour tous les logiciels ils
sortent des versions d'essai avant
d'avoir corrigé les erreurs
non il n'en est pas question je vois
qu'il a réussi à te convaincre mais
crois moi c'est trop tôt peut-être plus
tard quand on sera certain que tout le
monde est mort mais pas avant
j'ai essayé de lui parler de ton idée de
partir avec des camions chargés de
matériel et de la nourriture et d'aller
tous se réfugier quelque part dans le
désert dans un endroit isolé à des
milliers de kilomètres de la
civilisation et s'est posé là bas moi je
suis pour
regarde ça j'ai prévu un plan et j'ai
même fait une liste il ya tout ce qu'il
faut emmener là dessus on aura ces
places c'est encore trop tôt je suis
d'accord on sera à l'abri nulle pa et là
bas pas moyen de s'enfuir ni de se
cacher waouh t'es fini c'est ouais ça a
l'air génial merci
regarde ça ça c'est la cage qui protège
les circuits je crois que je vais en
fabriquer un deuxième et je vais faire
un système de communication entre les
deux robots après je ferai des répliques
et ont pour en mettre un peu partout et
il montrant la garde pour nous et on
pourra se reposer un peu plus et on se
retrouvera avec des jouets inutile et on
aura perdu du temps parce qu'il faudra
que tu les réparent hockey
quinze minutes de pause et on se serre
d'ici préparez-vous pendant que je monte
la garde
et pourquoi tu es si dur avec lui tu
crois que c'est une vie pour lui être
toujours en train de courir et de mettre
sa vie en danger
ils s'allument
si tu arrives en ethernet
[Musique]
avec moi
c'est foutu on est piégé pépère
on n'a qu'à se mettre dans un coin et on
les buts tous quand ils arrivent et nous
laisse assez de munitions pour sa
négatif ils sont beaucoup trop nombreux
on approche de la fin
ils deviennent encore plus agressif
juste avant la fin
ils sentent et ils entendent à des
kilomètres ramasser vos affaires si on
était dans un couloir avec une zone de
tir réduite d'accord mais cette fois ils
vont arriver jusqu'à nous de tous les
côtés on pourra rien faire mon amour
c'est toi mon amour n'oublie jamais ça
d'amour
et rien d'autre qui ponctuent comprend
iq
yahoo c'est l'espoir suffit de bien
regarder autour de soi
ok ok ok ok
pour qu'on aille tous se planquer
là-haut d'accord on fait en sorte qu'ils
se retrouvent tous piégés à l'intérieur
et y'a plus qu'à faire exploser le flou
ouais pourquoi pas ça nous fera gagner
un peu de temps avant la prochaine vague
on n'a rien à perdre je vais aller
accrocher une corde là bas aller
chercher les explosifs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le vide
3 au détonateur
je te rejoins pas y aller
plus vite aller
aller plus vite bausch pourra pas y
arriver et
puis mon naturel qu'on travaille l'été
avant
et
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi vous m'avez pas laissé là bas
c'est un homme mort on est tous morts
c'est pas beau à voir mais ça va aller
elle est morte mais toi tu es en vie
quoi tu fais ça pour elle pour cette
[ __ ] pour cette [ __ ] d'hypocrites
ferme là tu m'entends tu es pas j'suis
pas quoi [ __ ] de merde j'en peux plus
de jouer à ce petit jeu de toute cette
hypocrisie
qu'est ce que vous croyez elle croyait
quoi elle qu'est ce que vous vous
imaginez vous croyez que si vous aidez
votre prochain si vous êtes gentils avec
les gens autour de vous ça va vous
absoudre de toute responsabilité pour ce
qui est en train de se passer en ce
moment l'essence de la vie c'est le
meurtre et la souffrance
à chaque fois que vous consommez quelque
chose ça justifie le meurtre d'êtres
vivants les plantes et les animaux
fonctionne pas comme ça les plantes les
animaux
à chaque fois que tu allumes la lumière
ou que tu prends ta voiture
quelque part quelqu'un meurt d'un cancer
du poumon à chaque fois que tu achètes
une fringue pas cher il ya un gosse qui
meurt dans un atelier du tiers-monde ses
six filles qui est en train de raconter
n'importe quoi qui délire là c'est
dingue ça ouvre un peu les yeux tu sais
que je suis mal mais tu fais comme elle
te dis comme soignants en atténuant ma
douleur
ça va faire de toi une bonne personne
amour j'arrêtais pitié mon cul ouais si
tu fais ça c'est juste pour toi tu vaux
pas mieux qu'elle
tu fait que fuir et tutu pour survivre
et pour ne pas tuer et ta soeur aussi
elle aussi c'était une tueuse tout comme
nous autres
tu peux me dire ce que tu veux mais je
t'interdis de l'insulté quand il vient
de faire l'insulté l'insultait
parlons-en un peu de cette [ __ ]
pendant qu'on y est pourquoi est-ce que
j'ai choisi cet hôpital est pas un autre
à ton avis hein pourquoi
ça faisait partie du programme cet
hôpital faisait des recherches qui
faisait partie du programme
je suis venu ici en espérant trouver des
sujets de recherche
j'étais curieux mois curieux de savoir
comment mon projet se déroulait non j'ai
effectivement je te crois pas depuis le
départ depuis tout ce temps tu serais je
savais bien sûr et tout ce que l'autre
connard a raconté avant de mourir
c'était vrai je suis dieu
j'agis dieu qu'est ce qu'elle croyait
cette [ __ ] quand elle l'a tué elle
voulait pas que je me sente coupable
elle voulait éviter d'avoir à affronter
la vérité
cette espèce de kaunas ignorante se
connaît la vérité je sais qui je suis et
ce que j'ai fait c'est moi qui ai lancé
l'idée de faire cette expérience et moi
seul j'ai organisé les réunions j'ai
rédigé les rapports j'ai poussé me
laisser persuader contraint alors j'ai
falsifié les signatures les dirigeants
n'auraient jamais accepté que ce soit
mais comme moi qui tient les ficelles
alors fallait la jouer fine
c'était mon pb l'aboutissement de toute
ma carrière
tout ça à toute cette expérience
monstrueuse
ça pouvait pas être pire je les ai tués
tous tuer j'avais le doigt sur la
gâchette
c'est moi qui ai voulu que ça arrive on
est des meurtriers moi j'ai eu un peu
plus de succès que les autres c'est tout
mais ta soeur à la sainte elle qui est
si parfaite elle travaillait sur cette
expérience dans son hôpital
non je ne crois pas il n'aurait jamais
été un crois jamais fait quoi cette
espèce d'imbécile
elle était en vie donc elle était
coupable
vous voulez me sauver c'est impossible
je suis marc les infectés m'ont pas
attaquer moi parce qu'il m'avait déjà eu
depuis le départ et il n'y a aucun
remède
je le sais parce que j'ai fait en sorte
qu'il n'en existe jamais ça va aller tu
es malade tu dis n'importe quoi on est
tous malades
c'est pour ça qu'on est en vie sur cette
terre la vie est une maladie on est tous
des meurtriers toi ta soeur ton père
tu vois
un petit écran
tu veux gros on va faire ça proprement
on va laver l'habiller et on le mettra
dans un bateau comme un vix qui selon
les règles
après on trouve deux camions quand les
charges avec tout ce dont on a besoin
rions fonce vers le désert
il est possible qu'aucune de ces
théories ne soient correctes et
peut-être qu elles le sont toutes
peut-être n'y at-il pas eu un seul
événement peut-être que cette extinction
n'a pas eu une origine unique mais
résulte d'une combinaison d'éléments
dont certains sont reliés et d'autres
non quelque chose a détruit le fragile
équilibre de l'écosystème des dinosaures
peut-être les dinosaures eux-mêmes
peut-être les petits rongeurs
quoi qu'il en soit c'est lorsqu'il était
le plus vulnérable qu'une météorite a
percuté la terre provoquant une série de
tremblements de terre et d'éruptions
volcaniques sur toute la planète
[Musique]
la météorite les éruptions volcaniques
et les tremblements de terre le
déséquilibre aucun de ces éléments on
aurait été à lui seul suffisant mais
c'est leur combinaison qui a permis
c'était fondremand général
[Musique]
montaut
mais certains disent qu'en fait c'est un
virus qui a produit cet effondrement est
en réalité c'est la théorie qui semble
la plus logique
ma
[Musique]
ouais